Leslie in your TED talk I believe you
said that you SAT your family down
initially and said to them I need your
blessing to do this film because I will
not be able to look at myself in the
mirror and and feel okay about not
making this movie what was that
conversation like it was difficult
because my daughter was 13 and I knew
she needed her mother and she and I have
an extraordinary bond so I was mostly
addressing her my son was 16 and a half
he could have well lived without me in
fact I think he was rather pleased um no
that's not true he's a sensitive
beautiful boy my husband is used to
having me away he's an extraordinary man
with the most educated heart who
understands the gender should know no
boundaries and no restrictions and it's
a partnership so he takes care of the
kids when I work and that's you know
been quite quite often that has happened
but my daughter needed me so it was very
important for me to communicate to her
because I knew I was going and that's an
admission because I was ostensibly
asking her permission but actually I was
telling her I was going and and I said
look you are my priority if you ask me
to stay if you tell me you need me I
will stay but and I didn't let her
answer the question so it was a form of
emotional blackmail I'm ashamed to say I
said if you don't let me go in other
words you tell me you need me I'll never
be able to look myself in the mirror
again because I feel so strongly about
this I have to act on it and she just
said of course you have to go and that
was that was it a decision well I'm sure
she heard you speaking of the story
before hand and and all the
conversations yes in fact she SAT and
watched a lot of those reports you know
indeed the very first reporter of the
rape itself though that wasn't what had
got the fire in my belly because I knew
this was the tip of an eye
I mean we've all seen on a daily basis
these brutal hate-filled very violent
gang rapes and rapes and abuse of women
and girls happens ubiquitously across
the whole world it was the protests it
was the response to that that motivated
in fact compelled me to go because here
was a country doing what I feel every
citizen in every country should be doing
all the time until we get true gender
equality and you know the time really is
now to start demanding this with
certainty in fact last weekend or the
weekend before there have been a spate
of gang rapes of little girls in Delhi I
mean they're going on all the time but
there's been a spate of two very brutal
ones reported the weekend before last a
little four-year-old girl was gangraped
by three adult men she was slashed from
vagina to amos her face was slashed she
lay in the same hospital that Jyoti
Singh layin safdarjung hospital and she
had an operation just as Jyoti had that
lasted three hours to fit her with a
colostomy bag four years old and she
died a few days later and that knees I
heard on my Google Alert on the way to a
screaming that we had in London to mark
the day of the girl it was on that day
and I was so hurt and so in you know
infuriated by this I and Bianca Jagger
who was there to support the film that
night we both were just so outraged we
called on the audience that night to do
a call to action of all women and girls
across the world on the 8th of march
next year we want every woman and every
girl and every enlightened man to come
out on strike and let the world come to
a standstill as it will as it did in
Iceland some years back when women
simply stopped they stopped taking care
of the kids
they stop their subordinate roles with
their you know male bosses in much more
prominent positions with their
entitlement and they the whole country
and financial institutions came to a
standstill so we are calling on everyone
who is enlightened who cares about
gender equality to go out on strike next
March the 8th March the 8th oak
international women's day
you